half these chicks are on drugs anyway
that's what I found out so many female
influencers take like testosterone and
all that stuff you'd be surprised are
you natural or not oh please don't lie
please am I natural or not that's for
you guys to find
out I'm not even convinced that's a
woman so just guess huh take a wild
guess what I don't know what they're
going to say well unless you tell them
no I'm I'm not I'm natural you're
natural yeah lifetime so sad boy look at
her forehead there's nothing natural
about this chck natural yes how do you
think I keep my
face so lifetime natural and what
division you compete in bodybuilding
okay so men or sorry women's
bodybuilding yes